people who were nearby when this severe
weather hit walked us through what they
saw Madison Kimbrough was in Mesquite
tonight she joins us live with the
latest Madison
yeah we spoke to those either Leaving
Las Vegas or coming back to Las Vegas
from their trip to Utah but all were in
agreeance that today's weather was very
out of the ordinary I have friends from
Kansas and I texted him like guess what
we're like we're getting tornadoes and
they're like they can't believe it
Sunday the National Weather Service
issued out several warnings one of which
caught everyone by surprise a tornado
warning issued in Northeast Clark County
near Mesquite the warning ended around 5
15 p.m but was followed by a
thunderstorm warning many people posting
what they saw to social media like Brody
cowing who lives all the way in St
George Utah but could see from afar what
was going on I had my camera and I was
shooting to the West because there's a
storm that way then I just looked South
and that's where I saw the funnel for
the first time it just slowly manifested
and got it it got more defined and it
was just crazy to see and those on the
road say the weather didn't deter them
too much while driving as some had no
idea that a tornado warning had been
issued at all it was a little surreal to
just watch the clouds and the lightning
go if we had seen the tornado warning I
probably would have panicked because
it's not something that we're used to so
we would have been looking for
um
the nearest place to pull off
[Music]
and according to the National Weather
Service the last time Clark County was
issued a tornado warning was 15 years
ago that was in September of 2007.
reporting live in Mesquite Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now